by my count there were around 12
underrated developments in AI over the
last few days but they may have to stay
underrated for just a moment longer
because the 13th Manus AI has millions
of people on its weight list and maybe a
100 million people talking about it so
for just a few hours Gemini's New Image
editing feature the rise in reward
hacking Open ai's Secret creative
writing model and just about everything
else will have to wait to be honest Mana
says a lot about the AI landscape for
both good and Ill so let's get started
before I show you my tests and
comparisons to deep research grock 3
deep search and Gemini's deep research I
want you to think to yourself about what
the perfect hype campaign would be for
me it would start like this call your
product a glimpse into potential AGI
what other AI stops at generating ideas
Menace delivers results we see it as the
next Paradigm of human machine
collaboration and potentially it glimps
into AGI then put your product behind a
weight list but give Early Access
prioritizing those who you think might
hype your product a perfect outcome
would be comments like this one that
China reached AGI with Manus before we
saw GPT 5 next to create enough scarcity
the invite codes are being offered as
competition prizes on Twitter and even
better if you can create stories that
they are being resold for thousands of
dollars online if that was true I could
very quickly mint it because I was given
multiple invite codes of course it's
also definitely wise to delay mentioning
that your model is based on Claude
because that would slightly dampen down
hype and also explains why your website
is blocked in China because that model
is blocked in China oh and as a cherry
on top mentioned that you have
benchmarks plural but then only provide
a single Benchmark and of course while
you're at it make bloody sure that that
is a benchmark that you outperform your
rivals on now of course with that long
run I am being awfully cheeky because
Manis is actually fairly cool the team
behind Manis have been kind to me so
it's almost a little bit rude for me to
do that rant but I just couldn't resist
giving you a quick insight into how the
hype machine works I'm sure that every
single industry has its own hype
Merchants it's just that in a field as
important to the Future as AI I don't
want you guys or anyone to fall into the
extremes the extremes being that every
new development is just one click away
from automating everyone's job and the
Other Extreme being that AI is just all
hype and there's just literally no
substance there at all just quickly
though while we're on this particular
guia Benchmark which was written in part
by Yan Lun famously a skeptic of llms I
and perhaps you are quite impressed by
these scores compared to open Aid
research the problem is it is a public
Benchmark so we are slightly rying on
trust that they didn't over optimize to
game essentially The Benchmark for
example because the answers are public
you could keep training your model and
optimizing it until it reached a certain
bar on this particular Benchmark for the
few of you who haven't actually heard of
Manus AI what is it and what does it do
well it's a bit like a combination of
open ai's operator and deep research
systems think of operator as an agent
that can take actions on your computer
it can click things and indeed book
restaurants do that kind of thing
operator can be fair cumbersome though
and require a lot of babysitting where
it'll do one thing at a time and then
ask you another question in contrast
deep research after clarifying your
query we go off and search in this case
37 sources in 14 minutes and produce a
comprehensive output deep research in
particular I think is great but the
reason that operator and de research
aren't particularly popular or terribly
widespread is that until very recently
they were limited to the $200 tier
called the pro tier from from open AI
the final bit of context comes from
Claude projects which you may or may not
be familiar with which you can think of
as interactive previews of the work
you've done with Claude put all of that
together and ignore every single bug and
you have Manus AI I ask for example
create a simple website densely packed
with text about what happened with llms
in March 2025 lit up only by the cursor
which is acting as a flaming torch
notice the model would have to do a
fairly comprehensive web search all deep
research to find out everything that
happened with llms in March 2025 but
then also do a clawed project to make an
interactive website and then it would
have to come up with this little window
so like open ai's operator you could see
it taking actions in real time in fact
you can stop it and guide it and when it
all works it's pretty impressive here is
that website and I had to do pretty much
nothing to get it working like this and
that is where Manis is great tying
together all of these disperate
capabilities albeit not being incredible
at each of them but tying them together
into this one agent but let's get a few
things out of the way to dispel some
false Notions Manus uses dozens of tools
and several models but the key model
behind it as of today according to a
person with direct knowledge of the
situation according to the information
is Claude 3.7 Sonet and that model is
fairly expensive and Incredibly rate
limited which has led to one estimate
reported in the MIT technology review of
a per task cost of about $2 for Mana AI
before we rush then and call this
China's second deep seek moment we've
got to realize a couple of crucial
disanalogies with deep seek deep seek
made their own model Manis AI is a
compilation of other people's models and
second for me what made the deeps moment
was how cheap it was and how widespread
the availability was hence it rocketing
up the app charts at $2 per task if you
just did say five tasks per day you can
just calculate what the cost would be
over a month and yes this is probably
why even YouTubers like me who got Early
Access hit maximum daily usage limits
pretty quickly tell me what you think
but no I don't see Manis AI as the
second deep seek moment what about
quality though well in my opinion it
does everything really quite well but
nothing at state-of-the-art level let me
give you a few examples and try to bring
in comparisons with deep research from
open AI grock 3 deep search and even
Gemini's deep research yes the names are
confusing but Manus AI is multimodal in
the sense you can upload an image and
get it to perform a task based on that
image for example I said list the
founders of each company featured in
this image so we would have to recognize
the names of the companies and then of
course perform a kind of deep research I
tried this with all four of the tools I
just mentioned and I'm going to give you
the results in order of speed fastest
was deep research from Gemini Advanced
which told me that adding files is not
available yet that was done in less than
1 second which is quite impressive next
was grock 3 deep search which took only
2 and 1/2 minutes and analyzed 344
sources it was fast but skipped plenty
of the companies the results were
generally accurate but as you can see
here it said unknown Founders for a
bunch of these whereas I found it
relatively easy to find the founders for
quite a few of these companies Manis Ai
and open AI deep research took roughly
around the same amount of time about 15
minutes but the performance of Manis AI
was noticeably worse what I mean by that
is if you scroll down there were two
companies where it gave up trying to
find the founder that's curated Ai and
cian theep research finds the founders
of those companies and I double checked
and they seem to be Fairly reliable to
me for cian they're reported on the
website given as well as crunch base and
for curated AI in a fairly popular
magazine I'm Not The Only One Of course
to report accuracy issues there are
plenty of Reports online like this one
where Manis AI was asked about the
gaming console market and ignored
Nintendo switch it would be far easier
for me to just hyperventilate about all
the things it can create and the
research it can do if I don't check the
accuracy let me try to give you another
example and trust me I want to be as
Fair as possible to Manus this time I
gave all four of those agent tools that
I mentioned a kind of metat task to
research about each other create a table
comparing deep research from open AI
Mana AI deep research from Google deep
search from grock 3 with rows for at
least 10 features price speed and 20
clickable sources on this one arguably
Manus did as well as deep research it
took far far longer around 20 minutes
but I don't know if that's because of
the rate limits that are going on at the
moment cuz so many people are using it
or if that's just an inbuilt limitation
this is what Manis came up with and if
you can't see Gro 3 that's because the
UI of Manus is a lot more Jank compared
to the others the output is solid if not
entirely reliable let me give you two
examples first on the cost per query it
said it cannot be calculated for itself
Mana AI now while it's true that pricing
is not public as I showed you earlier in
this video there are some public
estimates about the price $2 per query
okay you might say that one's debatable
but how about this one towards the end
it said what about performance metrics
for Manis no published Benchmark results
its own website gives the guia Benchmark
on the column right next to it it quotes
The guia Benchmark for open AI deep
research so if it can't be fully relied
upon to quote its own Benchmark results
then it does make you wonder did it
fully deserve the absolute cacophony of
hype that it got in recent days let's be
fair though it did give me 20 clickable
sources for me to conduct further
investigation which is what I asked for
the research from openai only gave me 15
sources and worse than that it didn't
give me a table it gave me bullet points
and that was pretty disappointing it too
didn't site guia although it did link to
an article which mentioned guia so
that's kind of slightly better for deep
research grock 3 did a commendable job
but you could tell it was drawing on
less compute because the table at the
end felt a bit rushed its own res Arch
had confirmed that deep research was
available for 10 queries per month to
the plus tier but this wasn't covered in
the table again its research had
highlighted certain benchmark scores but
these weren't mentioned in the table
Gemini's deep research did a decent job
it was very quick but the table was
fairly scanted on detail this is
definitely not to say that Google Deep
Mind aren't cooking though and there are
plenty of developments from that company
that I want to cover very soon on the
channel now like operator Manis can do
things like actually book things for you
but according to all reports and my own
experience I would really caution
against necessarily trusting it that
much to do so Manis AI for me is very
much then fitting into the pattern that
I've seen for four trends that have
emerged in 2025 I did a video on this 5
days ago for my patreon and the trends
are that models are getting pricier they
are very patchy in performance they have
epic moments but can be internally
deceptive I will have much more to say
about reward hacking on this channel
very soon here then for me is the lesson
of this video which is this kind of
marketing actually works 2 million
people have signed up to the wait list
and there is something there right as
you've seen in this video Manis AI is a
great compilation of different tools and
models and often gets the job done but
because this quote sophisticated press
push end quote reported in an interview
with Shia Hong the founder of Manis AI
was so successful expect more of it
expect an endless list of new companies
pushing these YouTube campaigns and
tweet storms hype works there's just no
other way around it but if Manis AI
comes out at being say $200 a month I
personally would give it a Miss thank
you so much for watching but if you have
any interest in jailbreaking what I
wouldn't give a Miss is the grace one
challenges recently announced on their
website the links will be in the
description and they are sponsoring this
video and in particular look at this
competition started just 5 days ago you
can see the leaderboard here and know
you don't have to be a professional
hacker to get involved the prize poll is
over
$130,000 from my perspective you're
helping the models become more reliable
by Red teaming them in public so it's
kind of like a public service you know
what I'm kind of almost tempted myself
so it's probably time to draw this video
to an end thank you so much for watching
to the end and have a wonderful day